okay so I have finally seen Logan and
this isn't really gonna be a full proper
review of that because I got to it you
know weeks after release pretty much
anyone who really wants to see it has
seen it anyone whose opinion you really
kid around you would have already seen
overall it was good it was very good but
there's one specific thing that I really
want to talk about because it was the
one thing about the movie that drove me
nuts and I fully realized I might be the
only person that this bugged so this is
this is borderline nitpicky but it
reform II it really was that it took me
out of the movie thing and again it's a
good movie it's a very good movie and
pretty much everything aside from this I
was good Orla I was good with or loved
oh and uh spoilers like huge massive
spoilers so yeah if you haven't seen the
movie go away but um all the stuff with
the clone the x24 sort of younger you
know beastial Wolverine I was really
really really really really irritated
that that wasn't just Sabretooth Liev
Schreiber's Sabretooth specifically I
know I might be alone on this and I know
the reasons why it wasn't but I want to
just talk about why I wish it was so
first off as much as everyone wants to
disown everything about x-men origins
Wolverine and rightfully so to be fair
there's one thing that was good about
that movie legitimately good and Liev
Schreiber as Sabretooth was good his
dynamic with you Jackman was good his
look was great he was intimidating but
he was fun he enjoyed being nasty I mean
he was miles better than Tyler main as
Sabretooth who was fine in that original
as far as the look goes but they not
even a candle being held there and I
like Liev Schreiber Sabretooth so much I
actually been mentioned that I had
wished he had been in the Wolverine the
previous Wolverine solo movie now that
time I kind of let it go like part of me
a gun
it would have been nice because the the
mutant villain of this Vipers kind of we
she's not great he would have been so
much better but I'd let that one go
because he didn't really fit that story
I'm not sure he would have slaughtered
in there very well
and I had kind of come to terms of the
fact that Liev Schreiber was probably
not going to show up in Logan a long
time ago kind of on the same assumption
I assume there's really gonna be nowhere
to slot him in let it go but then I
watch the movie and there's a perfect
place to slot him in this version of
Wolverine that's younger and harsher and
is just more savage ibly that could have
been saber - there's no reason why it
isn't and before you people start
yelling at me in the comments yes I get
the idea
I get that Logan had at the end of his
life volume art has to literally fight
the vicious savage killer version of
himself they are literal izing that as a
metaphor I get what it's doing I totally
get it
and if Liam Schreiber as Sabretooth was
not a thing that existed I would have
been fine with it in a vacuum it works
but just the instant he showed up I was
immediately I wish that wasn't me thing
they even gave him
they gave him saber tooth's
close-cropped hair and the beats dub
sideburns it looked like him in the
shadows for a hot second it was and
beyond just really hoping Liam Schreiber
in this role it would have given us
closure on that cuz we never got it
we really didn't x-men origins Wolverine
very deliberately didn't give us closure
because obviously he had to survive
because the character shows up
chronologically later as far as the
events of that are unfolding go and
since Sabretooth never showed up
in a chronological story that happened
after the events of that first x-men I
suppose as possible he died in that
fight but first of all no based on what
we know about him and what he hadn't
already survived up to that point in
that movie alone no but even beyond that
even if I accept that he died on the
Statue of Liberty fighting Wolverine
that's not closure cuz Wolverine didn't
know who he was he didn't understand the
way to that fight
and it was a fight that was happening
just so worried to get past him to this
other thing it wasn't the point of what
was going on so that even if I accept
that that was their last fight that's
incredibly unsatisfying and like they
said I get why they didn't use him they
don't they don't want to remind anybody
of x-men origins Wolverine at all like
on any level whatsoever and I get that
bringing back the like the main
antagonist actor from that to play that
part one more time is sort of forcing
the connection it's forcing it back into
Canon to some extent I get their
resistance for doing that but for crying
out loud you brought back the adamantium
bullet and you felt free to have it work
differently and it did last time so why
couldn't you bring back Sabretooth and
not feel tied down to that other thing
where it was crap because you seem to
believe that the adamantium bullet was a
good idea so was he again I'm getting
myself a little worked up talking about
it because if I set this aside like
Logan was good and it was a good to end
was a good last story for this character
for this version of this character it
closed out Hugh Jackman's time as
Wolverine really really well it's just
this one thing this one thing and and it
wasn't even I thought about it later I'm
in the theater and when that young
version shows up instantly the instant I
figured out what he was and was going
I'm like that should have been
Sabretooth and you know what even if you
tell me that he died in x-men 1 I still
say this would have been Sabretooth
because it's a clone anyway so go ahead
and clone the one guy who had a tendency
to kick Logan's but quite a few times it
just gets to me because it was a massive
opportunity that I think would have paid
wonderful dividends again Liev Schreiber
in this part is so good and it would
have given closure to that I think they
just shrug their shoulders and when you
know everyone hated x-men origins
Wolverine so much so we don't need to
give closure to that story but you do
you do it's Sabretooth and Wolverine you
need to give closure to that story and
the yacht and the opportunity was the
hair as far as the story and the
narrative goes it was right there and
they they just didn't do it oh well
anyway like I said it's a good movie or
girl
list but that is my little just it's the
one thing that was it for me but that's
as close as I'm going to get to doing a
proper review of Logan so have you seen
the film yet what are your thoughts on
it whatever they are drop something down
in the comments let's talk about it
don't forget to Like subscribe check me
out on Twitter at Council of geeks give
a listen to the council of geeks podcast
available on iTunes and stitcher and
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Applause]